ok bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
sait-il plaisir ravi de vous retrouver
pour votre numéro dédié à vos idées
sorties tout de suite le sommaire de ce
vendredi 15 juin édition spéciale
grandement consacrée à la fête de la
musique le 21 juin le département va
vibrer au son du rock du blues du rap et
du jazz
de nombreuses formations à découvrir sur
scène à guyancourt montigny et voisins
le bretonneux le point sur la
programmation dans les yvelines
pour les plus gourmands ce week-end se
déroule le salon de la pâtisserie à
paris 200 exposants réunis porte de
versailles et parmi eux les moulins de
versailles fabricant de farine depuis
nous avons découvert entreprises enfin
ce dimanche 17 juin c'est la fête des
pères est comme toujours mais elle nous
proposera de créer un cadeau unique et
personnel une petite boîte à surprise ce
sera notre rendez-vous junior le 21 juin
arrive à grands pas comme chaque année
en fait l'arrivée de l'été en musique et
les yvelines n'y font pas exception
petit tour d'horizon de la programmation
dans le département tout d'abord à
montigny le bretonneux au coeur du
quartier saint quentin devant le muy med
rendez vous dès 19 heures la scène
accueillera le bagad de saint quentin
pour un panel de musiques bretonnes
il y aura aussi une initiation géante à
la zumba et puis un orchestre
professionnel prendra le relais smart
musique reprendra les plus grands tubes
connus de tous
on écoute ce josé cache un adjoint à la
culture suivi d'un extrait de la
formation sparte musique c'est un groupe
qui a nice tente de notoriété un
constitué de musiciens professionnels
qui d'ailleurs
sorte d'école de musique donc ce sont ce
sont de bons musiciens
c'est un groupe de variétés pop rock
internationale
ce qui est plaisant c'est là la
diversité de goûts ce qu'ils peuvent
interpréter parce que ça vous va aussi
bien avoir affaire à des morceaux pop
que rock le funk que ce que tout ce
qu'on veut
partout
ja
volley
il
[Musique]
via
la fête de la musique c'est aussi à
voisins le bretonneux cette année encore
l'espace culturel decauville accueillera
une douzaine de groupes et de chorales
sur trois scènes le 21 juin catherine
ata adjointe au maire en charge de la
culture veut nous présenter les
différentes formations bonjour bonjour
alors vous avez opté pour la diversité 1
cette année encore il y aura de tous les
styles on trouvera du classique de la
funk du rock et ça commence à 14h tout à
fait alors à 14 heures nous débutons par
les différentes chorales de nos groupes
scolaires qui vont pouvoir se produire
sur la le perron de la maison de coville
qui ça transforme et du coup en scène et
le public pourra les admirer donc si les
parents sont disponibles ils pourront
bien sûr les bienvenus
c'est une chance pour les écoles dans ce
qu'en plus elles n'ont pas forcément
française en ces enfants n'ont pas
forcément l'occasion se produire sur une
scène comme ça devant non non tout à
fait donc c'est le jour de la fête de la
musique c'est justement l'occasion qui
leur est donnée pour pouvoir se produire
et montrer tout ce qu'ils ont appris peu
durant l'année en fait et à 20h45 c'est
illicite dance alors qu'on prendra le
relais c'est une compagnie de danse le
hip hop bien connu en dans la ville ça
fait quinze ans qu'elle est installée à
voisins le bretonneux
oui alors à les installer sur deux
villes de l'agglomération il me semble
voisin est également mort pas c'est une
compagnie qui propose de la danse hip
hop en fait et je dirais que ça va deux
pas de 7 à 77 ans mais presque puisque
vous avez des groupes enfants vous avez
des groupes à dos mais aussi des groupes
adultes qui se produisent aussi sur
scène ont tué donneront deux
représentations le 21 juin la soirée va
ensuite continuer avec harmonie ski et
foulbazar small ben alors la c2
orchestre et puis il y aura du rock on
l'a dit jusqu'à la fin de la soirée
notamment la vie sur mars alors là c'est
un groupe qui nous vient de rambouillet
c'est les gagnants du tremplin rock oui
le tremplin rock c'est une manifestation
qui est organisée par multisons qui est
une association vie sinoise donc qui se
déroule alors de mémoire c'était en
février ou en mars
un dimanche après-midi lors de
c'est une chaire est un concours entre
différents groupes
il devait y en avoir quatre cette année
qui se produit chacun pendant 45 minutes
qui a un jury alors il ya des votes du
public et les votes d'un jury constitué
je dirais et à la fin en fait le gagnant
gagne le droit de se produire à la fête
de la musique de voisins donc la mission
d'annoncer les gagnants sur quel critère
est ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on sélectionne justement ces
groupes là alors en fait nous
travaillons beaucoup avec nos
associations à voisins puisque nous
avons la chance de bénéficier d'un tissu
associatif extrêmement riche
donc en fait nous faisons appel tous les
ans nous envoyons courier mail aux
associations en leur demandant qu'il
souhaiterait produire en fait et c'est
comme ça en fait c'est ce genre de
discussion que ça que le programme en
fait non tous les ans je vous propose
d'écouter un petit extrait justement de
la vie sur mars pour se donner un petit
peu une idée à quoi ça ressemble je
pense que tu prouves juste après
[Musique]
et
un billet sur
notre sur mars
ce que janvier je te les hommes
notre site
mars
janvier je te les hommes
et
or ce morceau c'est plutôt une balade
d'un côté un petit peu planant on
imagine bien qu'ils ont des des titres
un peu plus rock'n'roll qui bouge bien
maintenant soutenir c'est assez
éclectique donc il y en aura pour tous
les goûts
comment est ce que vous avez choisi du
coup les différentes formations on en
arrive à tout site terme y en a aussi
qui viennent de mettre à saussan
notamment des groupes de reprises aussi
oui comme je vous disais donc on
travaille pour la musique je dirais plus
actuelles avec nos deux associations en
fait vite chinoise à la fois mais ta
sauce et huile qui sont donc qu'ils sont
nous a proposé la vie sur mars et mai
tassos nos programmes des groupes qui
qui viennent régulièrement enregistrés
dans leur studio ou qu'ils chiffrent
plus particulièrement l objectif
justement de cette manifestation c'est
de mettre à l'honneur les groupes locaux
se faire découvrir des petites
formations qui n'ont pas forcément à
l'occasion de se produire dans l'année
en fait complètement à la fête de la
musique à l'origine faut bien se
rappeler que c'était ça c'était
n'importe qui pouvait sortir sans
trottoir à jouer de la musique et puis
se faire connaître c'est fait plaisir de
jouer le plaisir d'être ensemble le
plaisir donc d'écouter de la musique
aussi ensemble donc c'est ce que l' on
veut reproduire tous les ans un voisin
c'est pour ça qu'on est très attaché à
faire cette fête de la musique nous le
jeu le 21 juin en fait le jour initial
et non pas sur un week end alors
quelquefois ça tombe bien pas bien enfin
bon là c'est en plein pendant le bac
comme d'habitude mais bon voilà c'est
quand même un événement familial et
c'est quand même un événement très
familial puisque en fait c'est en plus
dans un endroit fermé qui est là pour de
covile donc c'est c'est très convivial
vous avez buvette sur place de quoi vous
restaurer de quoi s'asseoir écouter la
musique passer un bon moment entre amis
ou en famille pour passer une bonne
soirée merci beaucoup je catherine
atteint d'être venu sur notre plateau
pour nous parler de la fête de la
musique à voisins le bretonneux donc on
le rappelle c'est le 21 juin
ça commence à 14h à l'espace culturel
decauville il y en aura pour tous les
goûts et pour toute la famille et c'est
bien sûr gratuit
pour le reste du département à
versailles ce rendez vous se tiendra à
la place sur la place du marché notre
dame à la cathédrale saint louis
plusieurs scènes thématiques rock gospel
ou électro installé dans la cité royale
à plaisir il y aura des musiques
traditionnelles bretonnes du jazz
manouche et du trip hop la maison-musée
ray
devos organise un concert de la société
musicale de saint rémy les chevreuse le
21 juin là aussi mais la ville quant à
elle vous donne rendez vous le 23 dès
12h30 différentes animations pique nique
minigolf et barbecues sont également
prévus et enfin à magny les hameaux là
aussi le 23 juin musique classique et
musique du monde résonneront à la maison
de l'environnement
il y aura aussi des ateliers
scientifiques ouvert à tous et
guyancourt aussi ce sera le 23 juin à la
batterie ce qui est espace scénique sont
prévues sur le parking des studios dans
la salle de concert et dans
l'amphithéâtre il y aura des musiques
traditionnelles irlandaises du rap avec
christophe du hard rock mais aussi du
blues avec des chamois qui ont fermé
cette page consacrée à la fête de la
musique pour parler d'un événement
gourmand
jusqu'à ce dimanche 17 juin c'est le
salon de la pâtisserie à paris deux
exposantes des yvelines seront présents
comme les moulins de versailles
fabricant de farine depuis 1905
ils nous ont ouvert les portes de leur
entreprise familiale un reportage
réalisé avec toki nirhy lanto du blé
local des machines françaises c'est le
credo des moulins de versailles
l'entreprise fondée par la famille shaw
des produits des farines pour les
particuliers et les professionnels
une passion qui perdure depuis plus d'un
siècle il valide chevais avait
à étampes dans l'essonne
fils on achevée
ailleurs dans l'essonne
et
un show des gens chaudet s'installer ici
à versailles en 1905
aujourd'hui sept personnes travaillent
ici les moulins de versailles ce sont
1500 tonnes de farine 40 et 30 tonnes
par jour voilà deux
idiot de la farine là
on va passer cette farine n'en avait
créés dans des silos
le silo qui traverse le moule
c'est des sujets
on en est
avoir une pâte homogène
des produits fabriqués à partir d'un blé
cultivé à moins de 100 km de versailles
pour obtenir de bonnes farine la
sélection est rigoureuse à nos propres
camions du rachat ressemblait donc ça
nous permet de le contrôler au départ à
l'arrivée
analyse et saclay à une signature et
défendre ses caractéristiques ensuite
suivant
la femme est nous qu'on va produire
pendant l'année
tv
dosage précis de chaque cellule pour
pouvoir faire une farine est toujours
constante qualité homogène
depuis un an les moulins de versailles
se renouvelle la marque envisage de
lancer une gamme bio autre nouveauté des
préparations sucrées fondant au chocolat
madeleine autant de recettes à découvrir
au salon de la pâtisserie
[Musique]
après les mamans c'est au tour des papas
dimanche c'est la fête des pères une
bonne occasion de faire un joli cadeau
mélanie pour ce rendez vous des juniors
qu'est-ce que vous avez préparé
alors pour une fois j'ai décidé de
plutôt créer l'emballage cadeau est pas
le cadeau lui même une petite boîte 100
% pour les papas comme toujours on
trouve plein d'idées sur le net
moi j'ai craqué sur une petite boîte
chemise cravate à faire à tout âge le
matériel est très simple des feuilles
cartonnées plusieurs couleurs une paire
de ciseaux de la colle ou du scotch et
pourquoi pas des go mettre des
paillettes tout ce qui vous passe par la
tête pour les plus jeunes n'hésitez pas
à imprimer le patron qui se trouve sur
le site qui va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran pour les plus grands on peut
même aussi créer son propre patron alors
la première étape
bien sûr on découpe au plus près des
traits pour éviter que la boîte soit de
guingois et bien sûr le découper pas les
traits en pointillés ça va permettre de
faire l'intérieur de la boîte et après
on attaque tout de suite à l'étape
pliage alors il faut bien appuyé sur les
clients pour que ce soit bien nettes et
en plus le plus dur en éventail c'est
pas les plus faciles à faire non alors
il faut rire pour que les pliant pardon
soit le plus net possible
il n'y a rien de plus simple on va
utiliser un petit ciseau mais le dos du
ciseau pour juste faire une petite
marque qui va après et d appuyer donc
l'aider oui ça c'est pas de couper mais
de faire une marque un qui aident à
plier et une fois la boîte fort mais il
reste à la ferme et avec du scotch ou de
la colle et oui si vous collez vous
pouvez aussi consolider avec un peu de
cash pour éviter que la boîte se défasse
parents ne fermait pas la boîte tout de
suite il faut y mettre des cadeaux alors
vous pouvez aussi mettre un tout petit
mot un petit poème
moi j'ai notamment choisi un texte de
pierre rumeau et que j'ai roulé comme un
parchemin et si votre papa groupement
pourquoi pas des bonbons des petits
gâteaux
vous pouvez après fermer la boîte et
dernière étape la décoration est oui
alors pourquoi pas un petit ne pas
fouler cravate moi j'ai choisi la
cravate bien si
alors le patron il se trouve aussi sur
le site qu'on a affiché tout à l'heure
un petit peu de colle un petit peu de
scotch payet baumettes si vous voulez la
dernière étape par tonkam ici la plus
dure il faut attendre dimanche et voilà
la jolie boîte à faire pour vos papa
merci beaucoup mélanie mais si tu te
loisirs est maintenant terminée on vous
retrouve andré prochain pour un nouveau
numéro
d'ici là pour vous souhaite un excellent
week end
oui
oh